oh hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to dark deception now
dark deception has been updated to
chapter two so let's find out exactly
what lies in store for us in the new
chapters here we go
chapter two into madness hahahaha yeah
okay new game oh god no oh hey Pierce is
that you I've already been through this
before
that's what they all say already been
through that joke before hurts just as
much Pierce's ballroom uh-huh thank God
I don't have the eye tracker turned on
right now anyway
holy [ __ ] I do have to go through the
first one again okay alright I've done
the first chapter already so it
shouldn't be too much of a problem for
me to do it again oh god damn it damn
you damn you to hell you stupid monkey
this is this gonna be slightly boring as
I get through everything else not
completely boring but slightly boring no
I'm gonna die no easy peasy not gonna
die ever again what is the big red shirt
do oh oh that's handy oh okay what no oh
resume yes please resume resume on that
one to resume
yeah just resume oh no oh god oh god no
that was not fair that was unfair to the
extreme
no thank you oh no good good good good
you buy me probably see if I can scoot
this way no God oh hey got it easy peasy
not even a challenge
hey beers Hey pretty impressed by my
performance huh
place it at the altar now okay you got
it
why are you doing that face that face is
weird don't do that face okay so now yes
I am that's why I'm back for Chapter two
baby
alright chapter two is now officially
underway I don't recall putting the ring
piece on there but I guess you are the
boss you are the tall tall boss ah the
ceilings so interesting trying to keep
my eye line as high as possible hello I
don't think you like me very much
oh oh I get what you're saying okay so I
need to go to the brink Wow cool 8.5
what I'm so cool oh right QED
oh look at me go oh whatever man nerd
look at me go all right okay I'm gonna
zip past these like nobody's business
watch me who these thingies weapons are
gonna stake me when I activate turbo
speeed that's what I thought that's what
I thought that's what I thought that is
what I thought
Elementary of evil oh no elementary evil
sorry I thought that was elementary of
evil oh yeah
no not at all actually
how much sweet innocent baby right now
I'm just an innocent young child at
heart anyway okay get ready for oh yeah
run face first into it oh that's what I
thought oh that's a problem well glad
I'm here
welcome thank you very appreciate that
oh this is not my stop I'm sorry
oh oh that's awful
Oh okay all right you're just the best
okay all right I was hoping for that
Thanks okay here we go
great all right oh let's do it no no
wait no what no but I don't have a
tablet where's my tablet where's my map
huh
[Music]
huh okay one plus one equals rip man
your math skills need a lot of work I
can't exactly open doors either so I
don't even know if there are secrets in
this one what what oh no no no no no no
oh [ __ ] Oh
oh [ __ ] um uh uh can I burst through
this oh [ __ ] okay well oh that's a
problem what's boring whoa just speed
speed now boom I could think it's lasted
just a little bit longer this is going
swimmingly having fun you know it I am
having the most fun
all right I hate your face that's rude
I don't like yours either but you don't
hear me shouting it okay I guess nothing
else is gonna happen so I guess we'll
just carry on as if nothing else is
happening I don't know if it's just sir
because if it's just her it can't be as
bad as the monkeys because there was
like three monkeys okay all right it
says there's 167 left but have I even
seen like half of the school if that's
how many are left cuz I can't see any
new area here it just seems to be very
limited I'm doing a let's play right now
oh do you think I'm doing
god there's no shards we're the shards
cuz they're like a whole half of the
school that I haven't seen yet there's
one there okay
okay I'll find it I'm going for it I
imagine it probably gets harder there
too
okay here we go whoa oh hi oh hi No hi
no cake hi oh hi how are you I'm fine
thank you
vote Agatha for class president yeah you
want to tell me the joke no I'm pretty
funny I'm pretty funny guy
no I don't like that no thank you
okay can I open this nope okay all right
let's just no oh god oh no god I don't
like the sound of that Agatha Agatha was
here okay good good to know I'm just
saving my speed bonus by the way I'm
saving it because I don't want to use it
right away
I want to save it for when I need it
which is probably gonna be soon well so
far it doesn't actually seem any worse
though so I'm just gonna operate under
the assumption that everything is fine
Oh fun
Oh fun run oh that's a good room I like
that room that's a good one
No yeah I got an extra life I didn't
even use my life yet so that's good
what were you there oh [ __ ] you were
there climb off we know that's not
cheating you're cheating you just
teleported I could tell by the sound of
you teleporting nowhere where'd you go
nerd
oh that's hardly fair that's hardly fair
that's hardly fair she was supposed to
loop you around II totally fair told oh
okay no this is not okay that's not okay
bingo-bango who's that right by me
whoa no no no no no no no no no no hey
great I did it Oh No oh don't say daddy
okay oh okay wait that's not a portal
that's a trick I know that's trick oh
[ __ ]
I don't know where exactly I'm supposed
to go but try them I bet wow that's not
good mmm I'm assuming that the portal is
a bad thing and I shouldn't touch it I
never sleep hey neither do i funny two
peas in a pod oh oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I don't
know where I'm supposed to go I do we
I'm trying this real hard whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey whoa no need for that
see this is not fair cuz I don't know
which ways I'm supposed to go oh come on
really
that's what you do to me oh [ __ ] okay so
that is that is the way there but I just
got a gun it as hard as I can
okay I made it easy oh hi hello okay
can i no no oh boy
no no no I did it Wow for secrets okay
wow so sure it's all right hey bam bam
boom excuse me she was almost the same
age memories betray me here I need to
keep going I just need to survive a bit
longer seven more holy [ __ ] is that a
pirate blink can I get more speed boost
wow what is cool me oh cool down oh that
makes sense okay I don't know if this is
is this here can I do this I'm trying I
can give you the power to know
not with those spindly legs of yours I'm
talking teleportation teleportation you
say well goddamn I just spent on my
upgrade points though but I just I just
spent I would have loved to have more
doll cake
okay okay oh I see okay so E is Boost Q
will be jumpy watch this oh oh okay
boink
wow that's funky hello there we go
little buggy little buggy but okay hey
that guy looks fine deadly decadence
that sounds fun that sounds real fun I'm
down for that
wow really are they now okay hey buddy
beyond these gates of judgment awaits
okay all right hello never look away
never look away they're always watching
never look away never look away I wonder
what I'm supposed to do huh damn it I
didn't mean to use my speed he's got a
little zippy for this yeah hello how are
you
crackles are a bit loud oh no oh no
tread no further we are watching okay
but why though
don't watch me you're frickin weirdo
okay so do I just go in the front door
should I do that or should i teleport in
or what's deal oh no oh oh okay you paid
no heed now you shall bleed well yeah I
guess yeah okay
I'm gonna save the red one for no wait
oh no oh oh no oh no oh no oh no okay
our ski Oh who they were
oh they they zip poco they are they are
right zippy oh there there a right bit
zip
wow wow wow stop stop both of you stop
stop both of you stop all of you stop oh
I should watch out where I'm going huh
how do they are so zippy okay they even
stop if you're looking in the general
direction of where they are this is
gonna be tough I don't like the Oh God
there they go okay well I'm on my own
now no where are they hold on oh god oh
god oh god where are they
hold Oh horn Oh hard Oh Bob
well why would you be disappointed
explain to me why would you would be
disappointed haha okay let's just give
everybody a nice pause everybody hold up
a second
just get stunned don't kill me I'm just
trying to be a good thing they don't
kill you even if they're stunned ah hi
that was close very stupid of me but
okay
Oh God that corner that corner piece I
need the corner piece [ __ ] guy need
the corner piece you stop stop everybody
stop
whoo no you're not one you're not one of
them okay no okay it's fine it's fine
Oh what the hell oh god oh god that was
right Bobby no no oh God oh they're all
around me oh my god oh boy oh boy oh boy
okay where are they the answer is
they're close oh [ __ ]
I'm just trying to get them
conglomerated a bit okay there we go
I just wanted to get them in position
where I could probably keep an eye on
them oh oh oh oh oh oh this is not ideal
okay here we go this way like that okay
this way
maybe okay good good good good good
well no no no ah [ __ ] all right well
that crashed thank socks god I was so
close to done with that one - god dammit
that sucks but it's alright let's do
this and this time not suck ass but I
didn't die that's a good thing I did die
that one time that's cuz I ran straight
into this stupid thing I know it's so
funny I guess if I'm generally kind of
speedy about this they don't have time
to catch up okay I don't like that I
like that oh okay okay buddy
okay buddy okay don't yeah don't do that
we're going for we're gonna knit big
time baby big time oh you're still
pretty sippy you still almost caught up
to me
holy crap that's not fun oh wow oh wow
oh wow oh wow where are you where are
you ice I sensed you sensed you with my
ears again why would you be disappointed
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I'm a gear grab this
okay you're there great now I know must
done all y'all stunned get stunned baby
okay hopefully this will last long
enough that I could keep an eye on all
of them for the whole duration cuz I
know that them on the radar lasts longer
than them just being stunned oh they are
so fast okay yeah yeah okay no number
one no and number two no number three
big No here we go gunning it okay we're
going we're going we're going we're
going we got this one we got that one
god dammit why is it gonna be around
there oh boy we got this one we're
probably going to lose track
King soon but I think that's okay
we just lost tracking okay oh okay
where are they are they gonna be where
they where they go whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay so long as I keep them
generally in that vicinity I already
found one lady getting it oh [ __ ] can't
got it
can't get it can get it I can get it
okay here we go I'm going I'm going I'm
going too fast again lady wait how can I
I can't get out how do I get out oh I
probably got to go out the back way
maybe there's a back way yeah seems like
there might be a back way I don't like
that why do I gotta go through this
wagon oh why do I gotta do this for you
why do I gotta do this maybe if they
don't know it wouldn't hurt him he who
has gold makes the rules okay cool Oh
get the rest of the shards okay you got
it
okay divine judgment falls on peasants
through these halls great what did I do
Oh fun okay here we go wait what does
that do I don't know what that did oh
[ __ ]
what are they still doing that thing
whoa
you are you are still doing that thing
okay that's a problem um homeboy uh-huh
wait a minute hang on this is just the
one or is there more gasps Borg it might
just be the one guy but I'm not a
hundred percent sure oh [ __ ]
whoa Oh what the [ __ ] oh oh no okay no
damn it
oh [ __ ] there's more than one of you
okay that's a problem again many
problems oh there's three of you okay
well at least I got them all in one zone
oh no no no no oh [ __ ] that's more than
one oh boy that's not good Wow your face
is not fun
no okay for four of them four of them
really how is that fair please tell me
there's not more oh no oh no okay oh
[ __ ] they're both that way okay well
here we go
no thank you why why oh god oh god
don't know don't know nobody [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] I can't teleport through them god
damn it oh my god that's really hard
that's hard there's so many of them and
what does this switch do I don't know oh
is it just open this gate or something
oh I could trap them oh boy hi you suck
Oh God oh my god okay this is what the
[ __ ]
we're that I saw the red um the red
thing the red gem somewhere but I've
lost it now where where where okay one
there I can stun them qug unex they're
stunned good opportunity oh I missed
that one god damn that's gonna blight me
in the ass
where's the red locator gem I saw it and
it's gone and I really wish I had it
right now there it is
it's over there okay I'm gonna clear
this room first okay you guys are here
oh I hear another one coming that way
whoa whoa whoa okay there oh boy all
right that's no good okay
37 left this trackers gonna run out it
just ran out god damn it oh and they
split me god damn it stop being [ __ ]
no God you can't [ __ ] teleport
through them god damn it
oh [ __ ] I'm so close but I'm gonna I'm
not gonna make it cuz they're so they've
got to be so spread out oh my god oh
this is gonna be a nightmare
oh boy oh yeah there's one okay can i
scooch by you yes I can okay here we go
this way oh that was close no please
stop please don't [ __ ] oh of course
you are of course you are of course you
are
well [ __ ] white god damn it damn you
damn you damn you okay just got to get
around here no no no no oh why both of
you [ __ ] criminy last chance this
sucks this sucks the big dick ha this
sucks the big dick okay I gotta go this
way cuz at least this way is gonna give
me a direct route oh this sucks
of course you are of course you are Oh
[ __ ] course you are how many of you
are there okay what I'm gonna do is I
want them all in this room I just want
them all here so then they can get here
that's great too so long as they're all
in one spot let's assume that helped
Oh God [ __ ] of course uh Oh what
where am i oh my [ __ ] god oh [ __ ]
where are you just show your stupid face
alright can I not teleport around you
guys am i absolutely sure that that's
not a thing I can do and why can't I
cancel the teleport why can't I cancel
it okay so you can teleport around them
why oh [ __ ] of course I'm done I'm
done I'm done I'm done I'm done I'm done
no no that's just not fun no I'm good
thank you
I'm fine thank you thank you very much
I'm good I'm okay thank you I'm done so
that was dark deception I may have rage
quitted but I will be back when Chapter
three comes out and I will finish this
last segment of it and then I will
continue on with my life as if nothing
bad ever happened to me so it's a good
game I just got frustrated and I don't
ever want to play anything to the point
where I'm frustrated to the point where
I hate the game itself because the game
is good and it's a challenging gameplay
it's just like I got caught up into it
so I'll check it out again later
maybe I'll finish it up if there's more
content after this one but we shall see
in the future thanks again and as always
I will see you in the next video
but I
[Music]